before the Revolution began there were
approximately 556
000 people in Santa Minge in about 500
000 were slaves
like many other modern countries in the
Western Hemisphere Haiti comes from a
long history of colonization
it was initially called Saint domingue
and spent years as a colony before a
slave Uprising began in 1791.
slavery on the island was tyrannical
slave owners denied freedom to the
people and believed they could abuse and
even kill their slaves
the Rebellion turned into a complete
Revolution even though Western Powers
tried to quell it and foreign powers
were finally forced to surrender to
Haitian Independence in 1804.
even if they refused to acknowledge that
Independence for years afterward this
was the first and only time that a slave
rebellion led to a new country and it
started to change how many people viewed
slaves helping eradicate slavery in the
west over the next 100 years
the Haitian revolution has shaped modern
history and although the island has been
working through political instability
since the people's resilience displayed
internationally in the Haitian
revolution is still thriving today
how did the revolution begin
before the Haitian revolution began in
1791 the island was divided between the
French and Spanish
the French officially established their
claim to the Western third of the island
in 1697. the area known as Saint
domingue was incredibly fertile and
quickly became one of the most
profitable French colonies
they exported high-value Goods like
sugar coffee and cotton and the
colonists were determined to maintain
their favored and Wealthy status
however this success came at a cost over
the 100 years that France officially had
control over Saint domingue they brought
in approximately 800 000 slaves from
Africa
there was a high demand for labor and
the colonists used increasingly inhumane
methods to intimidate their slaves
throughout much of the 18th century
there were minor revolts and
conspiracies among the slaves but these
were unsuccessful because the colonists
were more organized than the slaves
as the threat of a slave revolt
continued to increase slave owners
treated their slaves worse in an attempt
to break their Spirits even though
several people warned the colonists that
harsh treatment would lead to Revolution
the treatment of slaves in Santa Minge
was said to have been worse than in
almost any other place in the Caribbean
the slaves outnumbered the colonists at
about a 10 to 1 ratio so the colonists
worked hard to keep slaves from banding
together out of fear
The Colony itself was also divided the
three areas had differing social status
and economic wealth so they had
difficulty banding together and
underestimated the ability of the
enslaved people
for a while the colonists kept all ideas
of Revolution and equality from their
slaves but when the French Revolution
erupted given the strict censorship
could not keep the news of the
revolution from reaching the slaves
the colonists saw an opportunity to
improve their standing in France the
revolutionaries also agreed that all men
were created equal and as Leaders began
to arise the slaves finally found a way
to band together against their
oppressors
they built an underground communication
network with over 200 leaders scattered
Across The Colony
they gathered secretly and planned the
Rebellion that would eventually lead to
Haitian freedom
although one group accidentally started
the revolution early and was caught the
colonists did not believe them when they
explained the whole plan
they ignored the threat of danger and
believed in their own superiority
however their superiority wasn't enough
to stop the Haitian revolution
in late August violence erupted in the
northern Province as groups of slaves
rebelled they marched across the region
killed or imprisoned any one of European
descent and set fire to plantations
the groups have been severely
underestimated and now the colonists
could not control them
they fled to the city of lecappe the
heart of the colony within 48 Hours the
slave rebellion had destroyed most of
the plantations in the northern province
they then began marching on the cap
although the first attempt to take the
city did not work the revolutionaries
began a siege that left the city calling
for help from surrounding islands and
the United States
the very people that the colonist set
oppressed suddenly had the upper hand
the revolution had begun and the former
slaves were much more prepared than
anyone had expected
why was the revolution successful
most slave rebellions throughout history
weren't successful the people were
usually ill-equipped or lacked strong
sustainable leadership to carry them
past an initial outburst the Haitian
revolution was very different
these people had taken time to plan out
the rebellion and pick strong leaders so
although not all the slaves had good
weapons they were well organized and had
the benefit of surprise
the Rebellion spread to the rest of
Santa Minge although it wasn't as bloody
in other parts of the colony
plantation owners were left without
anyone to work the fields and the French
army was struggling to bring the
Rebellion under control because they
were not accustomed to guerrilla warfare
by mid-september the slaves controlled
enough of the colony that they could
make demands like Freedom From Slavery
many plantation owners did not want to
concede because they didn't want to
reward them for crippling the economy
they didn't think of the slaves as
people so the slaves shouldn't know that
they should be trying to make life
better for others
the colonial assembly tried to broker
peace in late September by granting
citizenship to free men and mulattos who
were people of mixed ancestry
the French National Assembly revoked The
Limited rights to these groups three
days later
Brewing the revolution to new levels
before the people that believed they
were fighting for France but when the
French National Assembly revoked those
rights the revolution transitioned to
fighting for Independence
the revolutionaries change tactics now
determined to push the remaining
Frenchmen from The Colony and claim it
as their own
the fighting was brutal on both sides
the revolutionaries regularly raided the
remaining plantations and cities and the
colonists brutally murdered any
rebellious slave they captured including
women and children
as the revolution continued other
European powers began to involve
themselves seeking to take advantage of
France's weakness both Britain and Spain
joined the fight making alliances as the
situation evolved France found itself
fighting a war in Saint domingue and in
France as the French Revolution launched
into the reign of terror
the French government was in too much
disarray to focus on crushing a slave
revolt and the revolutionaries began
making more open alliances with France's
enemies to get the supplies they needed
the French government was desperate to
bring the Haitian revolution to a close
so in 1793 they began offering freedom
to any slave who joined the French side
in August 1793 legere somethingx issued
the general emancipation decree for all
slaves in the northern Province however
this decree did not have any government
backing so many of the former slaves
were still not satisfied even though
they were now considered laborers and
earned wages
the French were beginning to Grant the
revolutionaries some rights including
limited working hours and a full day of
rest each week but they were still
unsatisfied these former slaves did not
want wages they wanted complete freedom
and that included having land of Their
Own
one of the influential revolutionary
leaders was Toussaint levature in 1794
he rallied many of the different
revolutionary groups together under his
leadership and he helped to begin
pushing Britain out of the colony
his power continued to grow and by March
1795 he was so powerful amongst the
revolutionaries that he was able to save
governor general Laveau
the latter had been sent from France to
establish peace and ensured the new
labor laws were enforced
the mulattos had arrested him because
they were afraid he would take away
their Newfound power
Laveau was so grateful that he promoted
levature to lieutenant governor
however levature was not satisfied with
only being the lieutenant governor he
had big plans and prioritized his fellow
revolutionaries not the European
countries which would return his people
to slavery if given a chance
the French Have Become increasingly wary
of him and worked to remove him from
Power
by 1801 they had successfully ended
their Wars with Britain Spain and
themselves and had more troops to direct
towards ending the Haitian revolution
the French promised to restore
prosperity and as more of luvitzura's
forces joined the French and luvature
was arrested it seemed like the
rebellion was finally closing
the French might have been Victorious if
the revolutionaries had not realized
their plan to reinstate slavery like
they had in other colonies
the revolution erupted again
revolutionaries mobilized and restarted
their guerrilla warfare and the French
returned to the new race war killing any
former slave suspected of plotting
against them
desolenes was one of the strong leaders
who emerged in 1802
he began consolidating power arguing
that the Revolutionary should return the
violence from the French
under desolenes they killed any
colonists they found which had the
unintended side effect of driving
European interests away from the island
fighting continued until 1803 when
Napoleon finally lost interest in this
unprofitable War
the French surrendered and left the
island leaving the revolutionaries to
figure out how to build their own free
country
under desoline's bloodthirsty rule the
island remained isolated for years
unable to interact freely with the
outside world so although they were now
free their hardships were far from over
desolenes completely cleared the island
of colonists by murdering anyone of
European descendants who remained the
new constitution promised an end to
slavery although the new military
oppression was not much better
the Haitians had won their War but now
had a long way to go to create the free
civilization they had fought so hard to
win
how did the Haitian revolution influence
slavery in the West
the Haitian revolution did not lead to
the immediate emancipation of slaves in
the West for several years most Western
countries refused to acknowledge Haiti
as an independent country
there were shocked that a slave
rebellion had actually succeeded and
were fearful that recognizing former
slaves as free men might lead to an end
of slavery in their own countries
the implications of freed slaves seem
too much for the Western World to
consider seriously and they believed the
revolution to be a warning of what would
happen to their countries if they did
not correctly control their slave
populations
even though the Haitian revolution did
not end slavery in the west it did help
to start the process of ending slavery
slavery is a systemic issue that comes
from objectifying and dehumanizing
others
the revolutionaries proved that slaves
were capable of the same analytical
planning and tactics as any colonist the
French could not squash the Rebellion so
they eventually had to concede to
negotiate with them as if the
revolutionaries were also people
even though the French Revolution
proclaimed freedom and equality for all
they were forced to confront what that
really meant on the battlefields in
Santa Minge where they had to
acknowledge that people should not live
in slavery even if slavery helped
increase the profit margin
the Haitian revolution shook the Western
world but Hedy today is still not stable
because other Western countries refused
to recognize the country for years the
people were left without access to many
supplies they needed to rebuild
military leaders and Invaders ran the
land after the island declared
independence the first democratic
election was not held until 1990.
despite their years of instability the
Haitian people still have the same
determined Spirit to help them win the
only successful slave rebellion
they are continuing to grow and rebuild
so only time will tell how Haiti will
continue to influence world history for
the better
how would you like to get a deeper
understanding of History impress your
friends and predict the future more
accurately based on past events if this
sounds like something you might be into
then check out the brand new captivating
history booklet by clicking the first
link in the description to learn more
about the Haitian revolution check out
our book Haitian revolution a
captivating Guide to the abolition of
slavery it's available as an ebook
paperback and audiobook if you enjoyed
the video please hit the like button and
subscribe for more videos like this